♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE CONSEQUENCE OF A
DELUSION, THAT BREAKDOWN THAT
FOLLOWS AFTER TRUTH IS REVEALED.
>> [BLEEP]
[YELLING]
>> Greg: THAT PERSON IS GOING
TO DO WELL IN LIFE.
IMAGINE BEING HIS PARENTS.
I WOULD MAKE A JOKE BUT I FEEL
SORRY FOR THEM.
IT’S A BREAK DOWN WHAT YOU ALSO
SEE ON SOCIAL MEDIA WHERE
CELEBRITIES RESORT TO ALL CAPS,
INSANITY IN RESPONSE TO CHEEKY
MEMES.
TRUMP JUST REPOSTED THIS,
PROMPTING BETTE MIDLER TO SCREAM
FRANTICALLY "YOU THINK THIS IS A
JOKE, DON’T YOU?
IT’S NOT.
HE MEANS IT.
HE WILL CHANGE THE RULES.
HIS ENABLERS WILL LEAD HIM.
IF HE WINS AGAIN, HE WILL RULE
UNTIL YOU DIE."
AT LEAST IVANKA IS SEEN.
THAT MIDLER IS SO NAUGHTY,
ELEPHANTS KEEP TRYING TO EAT
HER.
AFTER TRUMP’S PRESSER, CNN GOES
FULL FREUDIAN.
>> THIS IS THE DISTURBING
TABLEAU FOR THE COUNTRY.
IT WAS DARK BECAUSE HE’S MADE
CLEAR HIS MIND IS DARK.
SUMMONING DEEP PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISTRESS, SELF-PITY, INSECURE,
ANGRY.
>> Greg: THAT IS A STRAIGHT
NEWS REPORTED.
CNN’S VERY BEST BECOME
PSYCHIATRISTS, DIAGNOSING MENTAL
ILLNESS.
NO SURPRISE THAT HE’S A PARANOID
NARCOLEPTIC.
I’M KIDDING.
BUT ANYONE CAN PLAY DOCTOR.
ESPECIALLY IN TIMES OF HYSTERIA
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE ELSE’S GOOD
TIME IS YOUR BAD.
EMOTION FUELS THE ANGER.
IT’S HAPPENED BEFORE, RIGHTEOUS
RAGE FOLLOWED BY DEPRESSION.
THE MEDIA AND THE DEMS.
THE ATTACKS ON TRUMP ARE MORE
PLENTIFUL AND INTENSE.
BECAUSE HE FOUGHT BACK.
REMEMBER WHEN PEOPLE MOCKED
TRUMP DEFENDERS.
HE FIGHTS.
IT’S WHY HE’S WINNING AND WHY
THE OTHER SIDE KEEPS SCREAMING.
I HAVE A THEORY THAT YOU SHOULD
ONLY TWEET AND ALL CAPS IF YOUR
HOUSE IS ON FIRE THEN YOU
SHOULDN’T BE ON TWITTER.
>> Dana: FOR PEOPLE ON TWITTER
A LOT, THEY THINK THEY’RE HAVING
AN IMPACT BUT THEY ARE TALKING
TO THEMSELVES.
IT’S LIKE SPITTING IN THE WIND.
IT GOES AWAY SO QUICKLY SO IT’S
KIND OF POINT IS.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE ROOT,
SPITTING IN THE WIND.
>> Dana: SOMETIMES IT COMES
BACK AND HITS YOU IN THE FACE.
TRY IT ON THE WAY HOME TONIGHT.
BERNIE BITES.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: HE’S NOT GOING TO
TAKE THE IOWA RESULTS LYING
DOWN.
>> Greg: I TAKE A LOT OF
THINGS LYING DOWN BECAUSE I’M
LAZY.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT VIDEO
OF THAT KID?
I THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY AND THEN
THEY LOOK AT IT.
WHAT’S WRONG WITH THESE PEOPLE
IN COLLEGE?
>> Lawrence: I COVERED COLLEGE
FOR TWO YEARS AND IT’S TYPICAL
BEHAVIOR.
IT’S PART OF THE PROFESSORS
PITFALL.
WE THINK --
I THINK JUAN HAS BAD IDEAS BUT I
LOVE JUAN.
THERE IS TALK ON THE OTHER SIDE
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES, THEY ARE A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, A THREAT TO
THE COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU HAVE THESE DEVELOPING
MINES THAT SHOULD BE LEARNING
BOTH SIDES OF THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM YOU PUT THAT NONSENSE
IN THEIR HEAD, THEY START
REACTING.
>> Greg: I HEARD THAT KID IS
ACTUALLY NOW GETTING A JOB AT
CNN AS A MEDIA REPORTER.
>> Juan: COULD BE.
MAYBE HE’LL REPLACE YOU, I DON’T
KNOW.
IT SEEMS TO ME, IT’S CRAZY TO
EXTRAPOLATE FROM THIS BAD
BEHAVIOR, CLEARLY THREATENING.
IF THE POLICE ARE AWARE OF IT.
THEY SHOULD BE CHECKING IT OUT.
DRUGS MAY BE AN ISSUE.
YOU CAN EXTRAPOLATE AND SAY IT’S
TYPICAL BEHAVIOR ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
IF YOU TOOK AN EXAMPLE OF A
RIGHT-WINGERS NOTHING CRAZY AND
SENT ALL REPUBLICANS ARE ALL
CONSERVATIVES, WE WOULD SAY NO,
IT’S NOT FAIR.
>> Greg: IT’S A TREND.
I HAVE THREE EXAMPLES.
>> Juan: TO ME THE BIG NEWS,
IT SEEMS TO ME.
TRUMP AND PEOPLE WHO ARE UPSET
AND I THINK LOTS OF DEMOCRATS
ARE UPSET AT THE IDEA THAT THERE
WAS A POWER PLAY THAT WAS DEVOID
OF PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT WAS
GOING ON THAN YOU HAD
REPUBLICANS WHO SAID HE DID
SOMETHING WRONG BUT WE DON’T
WANT TO IMPEACH.
IT’S LIKE PEOPLE ARE LACKING IN
SAYING CONVICTION AND HOLDING
THE PROMISE TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Greg: IT’S OVER, JUAN.
WE’VE GOT TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
STEP, THE NEXT IMPEACHMENT.
EMILY.
THE THING THAT DRIVES ME CRAZY
IS THE DIAGNOSIS, WHEN PEOPLE
DIAGNOSE PEOPLE’S PROBLEMS.
DOCTORS AREN’T ALLOWED TO DO
THAT WITHOUT SEEING A PATIENT.
>> Emily: I AGREE.
ALSO THAT VIDEO OF THAT GUY,
THAT’S MY ENTIRE METAPHOR FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW
WHICH IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LEADERSHIP ARE SCREAMING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR ECHO CHAMBER.
THEY ARE FUELED ENTIRELY BY
EMOTION AND CONTEMPT, THAT’S ONE
OF THE FOUR HORSEMAN, YOU MEMBER
THIS.
JOHN GOTTMAN SAYING ONCE YOU
HAVE CONTEMPT, THE WHOLE WORLD
WAS OVER.
HE CAN PROCEED WITH LOGIC
ANYMORE.
WHILE THIS GUY IS LITERALLY
GOING CRAZY SCREAMING AT WHAT HE
THINKS IS SO TRUE, ALL AROUND
HIM -- I’VE GOT TO GET TO CLASS
IN 20 MINUTES AND I’M
VIDEOTAPING THIS INSANE GUY.
ONE OF MY HAVING FOR DINNER?
I’VE GOT TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE THESE STATISTICS THAT
CAME OUT IN THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
THE DOW HAS BEEN UP ALMOST 60%
SINCE THE ELECTION.
S&P ALMOST 56%.
90% OF AMERICANS ARE SATISFIED
WITH THEIR PERSONAL LIFE.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT MATTER.
LITERALLY THE REST OF THE
PARTIES WATCHING THE LEADERSHIP
IN THE MIDDLE GO BESIDE
THEMSELVES MAKE NO PRODUCTION
WHAT SO EVER.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE ARE
GOING TO LEARN AT THE BALLOT BOX
WHO MADE THE MOST SENSE TO THEM.
IT’S NOT PELOSI.
>> Juan: 80% OF AMERICANS ARE
REPRESENTED BY THE SENATORS WHO